i mean this guy's like everybody loves
you when i'm drunk i guarantee you they
don't you you don't want to die before
your [ __ ] mom and dad this sucks man
like addiction's hard as [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
i'm actually
what's up chris um and your brother or
whatever um wow my name is john i'm a
big fan
um of chris
um but uh my problem is i need to stop
drinking i think like whenever i'm drunk
the right side of my like abdomen hurts
so i think my liver is having issues
um but i'm just such a better person
when i'm drunk like everybody likes me
more girls like me more i'm funnier i do
stand up and the best set i've ever done
i was blackout drunk
so i just feel like if i commit to a
fast life and drink you know more i'm
gonna have more success you know
career-wise and also just beautiful
women so
but if i you know stay sober then you
know be more mellow and like serious i
guess but
i'll live longer i don't know um let me
know what you guys think i've tried
switching my drugs up to give my liver a
break but nothing hits the same as
alcohol so
um yeah appreciate any advice and uh i'm
in la if you guys ever need an intern or
anything let me know yeah he sounds like
a good guy to happiness yeah dude i i
couldn't tell if he was joking i don't
know if you're joking or not but let's
take it serious since you actually asked
uh your
sounds like i'm no therapist but like
you're compartmentalizing and [ __ ] i
mean i was waiting for him to be like
yeah i mean i i don't know maybe he's
joking but that's kind of like he lola
put it this way he he's definitely not
joking about what's happening he does
probably do that
you know he does probably drink a lot
yeah but
your liver hurts right yeah but we don't
know if that is connected with the
drinking though i would i would i don't
know eventually take a break see what
happens take a week break if your liver
stops hurting it's the [ __ ] well just
go to the doctor too yeah if it persists
i mean i [ __ ] know how i know but
like uh it sounds like you're uh
compartmentalizing men and like you're
making excuses to kind of keep feeding
your addiction uh and you uh
you're calling in here maybe for some
advice or maybe just to be silly but
either way honestly it sounds like it
might be a problem and of course your
best set was when you were drunk because
people were laughing that you were drunk
but that doesn't make you a good
comedian that makes you uh funny drunk
yeah which a lot of people are it's not
unique yeah yeah so it's way harder to
be a good comedian bro and if you really
want to be a comedian then clean that
[ __ ] up and work hard at being a
comedian um also get your [ __ ] in check
also if you do stand up and you are
great when you're blackout drunk what
are you gonna do get blackout drunk
every time you go up on stage well
that's what i'm saying about living fast
and [ __ ] but here's the other thing too
dude people romanticize that thing man
if you were to go back and ask everybody
who [ __ ] died at 40 or whatever uh
was that fast life worth it
they're dead so they can't answer but if
they could they'd say [ __ ] no man you
want to see your daughters grow up your
[ __ ] sons grow up you want to see
your your fam you don't want to die
before your [ __ ] mom and dad this
sucks man like addiction's hard as [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] i'm actually
[Laughter]
just stop uh drinking too much and
stop
knowing it's hurting your liver
and then you can be better at everything
and not be wasted all the time because
no one likes i mean this guy's like
everybody loves you when i'm drunk i
guarantee you they don't yeah other guys
who enable you and are also drunk love
you when you're drunk and it's also
annoying man you're probably annoying
trust me yeah you're annoying when
you're drunk okay i used to drink all
the time i'm not even sober i just
stopped drinking because i i
but i believed i wasn't annoying i
believed i was the life of the party but
trust me i was annoying [ __ ]
yeah
i know that because i see drunk people
now and i'm like this [ __ ]
thinks he's the life of the party he is
instead of being the life of the party
the death of the party he is [ __ ]
annoying yeah you're like the guy that
brings out the guitar in the middle of
the [ __ ] party that everyone's having
fun at you're like okay i guess we're
gonna [ __ ] listen to some [ __ ] by
weezer now that isn't even good
like here's the other thing man like
coming from someone who absolutely has
an addiction problem
you got to figure your life out man you
got to do it for you it's [ __ ] so
hard but you can do it um
i don't know i would suggest
getting a group of people that
are
willing to help or a 12-step program
um
[Music]
and it's not
easy it's [ __ ] hard
and if you want to do the work
then do both works try and be a certain
and so far and try and be a comedian and
also try and live your life true
um and not and not
drink and die and affect everyone around
you and now yeah not blackout drunk also
don't you want to remember some of your
[ __ ] life like if you're blackout
drunk just because you can make people
laugh in your life for the party and as
you say beautiful women like you more it
doesn't matter if you can't [ __ ]
remember it who are you doing this for
other people are you it's yeah that's
true it's also not what people like
you for trust me bro
i thought people liked me because i was
the guy who would come in and get all
the [ __ ] ladies and be cool and
i was charismatic and i was funny but
dude that's not why people like you man
like people like you because you're you
and you matter
and it took me a long time to figure
that out so
he was kind of being a piece of [ __ ] to
me in the beginning though so i don't
think people like him for him maybe he's
better when he maybe he's better when
he's drunk it's funny dude because i get
a lot of videos that call me matt's
brother so i think we're even yeah but
if you go look at the youtube comments
everyone's like wow matt and his brother
are amazing so thanks for that buddy
[Music]